el equinoccio de primavera también
marcha de la llegada de un nuevo año en
varios países de asia central incluido
azerbayán afganistán y en irak donde la
tradición es comprar muchísimas flores
para adornar las casas en esta época de
los que realmente se extienden como las
vacaciones de dos semanas pero este no
lució particular tiene
y un elemento especial también marca la
llegada de un nuevo siglo para estos
países y es un nuevo siglo cargado de
retos incluidos irán donde la situación
económica del país es una de las más
críticas del último siglo como
consecuencia no sólo de la pandemia sino
esas traducciones económicas impuestas
por eeuu que ha hecho que la reacción y
el manejo de esta crisis de salud sea
muchísimo más dura a esto se incluye que
también este siglo trae el reto de ver
si se va a reactivar ese acuerdo nuclear
en el cual esas conversaciones con eeuu
que permitirán que se levanten estas
sanciones económicas y mejorar la
situación del país pero llegan un año
donde habrán elecciones presidenciales
quién será el nuevo presidente será uno
de los grandes
interrogantes a descubrirlo en guardias
revolucionarios esta fuerza militar que
surgió en esta guerra con irak en la
década de los 80 tienen aspiraciones a
gobernar este país y obviamente marcará
no solamente este año sino el nuevo
siglo político en irán